[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend Lena allen dieses Land wird
regiert von einer Koalition die sehr
vieles anders machen wollte gerade auch
im Miteinander was wir aktuell erleben
ist Streit wie bei anderen zuvor der
grüne Wirtschaftsminister hört aus der
SPD Zweifel an seinem Können der
SPD-Kanzler hört aus den Reihen der
Grünen Zweifel an seiner Performance da
geht es bereits dermaßen zur Sache dass
die Opposition sich schon anstrengen
muss um das mit ihrer Kritik noch zu
toppen Problem nur die Herausforderungen
werden deshalb kein bisschen kleiner und
sie sind aktuell das sagt dieselbe
Koalition vermutlich die gewaltigsten
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg wie also soll
Deutschland durch Herbst und Winter
kommen da sind zunehmend dringend klare
Antworten gefragt Daniel pontzen es ist
diese Tage im politischen Berlin nicht
immer leicht zu erkennen ob Aussagen aus
Regierungsparteien stammen oder vom
politischen Gegner es begann gestern
hiermit das Prinzip habe geht so
Auftritte filmreif handwerkliche
Umsetzung bedenklich und am Ende Zeit
der Bürger drauf sagt Dirk Wiese
Fraktionsvize der Regierungspartei SPD
Antwort die schlechte Performance des
Bundeskanzlers seine miesen Umfragewerte
Erinnerungslücken bei Warburg und seine
Verantwortung bei nordstream 2 werden
durch unloyales Verhalten und Missgunst
in der Koalition nicht geheilt werden
schreibt Konstantin von Notz
Fraktionsvize der Regierungspartei die
Grünen es folgte eine Ermahnung zu
fairem Umgang miteinander allerdings
nicht vom Kanzler sondern nächste Pointe
von ihm
ich wäre nicht zu brutal wie der grüne
Abgeordnete Netz zum Bundeskanzler das
würde ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht
trauen so hat zu argumentieren ich rate
dringend aber zu Ergebnissen in den
Beschlüssen dafür präsentierte die
SPD-Fraktion nun eine Beschlussvorlage
mit zahlreichen Vorschlägen etwa
Direktzahlungen unter anderem für
Rentner und Studierende eine Strom- und
gaspreisbremse
Kündigungsschutz für Mieter eine
übergewinnsteuer für Energieunternehmen
und für den Nahverkehr ein 49
euro-ticket auch noch mal schriftlich
vermerkt die Aufforderung die gasumlage
neu zu justieren sodass gesunde
Unternehmen nicht Trittbrett fahren
können eine Erinnerung daran wer dieses
Trittbrett sozusagen montiert hat kam
vom dritten Koalitionspartner und Klang
ebenfalls ein bisschen wie Opposition
bei der gasumlage ist der
Wirtschaftsminister bemüht und auch
gefordert die
Fehlentwicklungen zu korrigieren ich
erwarte auch dass die Bundesregierung
sich dringlich beschäftigt mit den
Entwicklungen am Strommarkt hier ist ja
mein Kollege Robert Habeck zuständig
beides komme versprach der doch bis der
Energiemarkt reformiert sei so auch
seine Forderung müsse die
übergewinnsteuer her eine marktreform
ist ein komplexes Unternehmen das muss
auch sorgfältig gemacht werden wenn das
nicht schief geht dann kollabiert der
Markt und dann haben wir ein ganz
anderes Problem in Deutschland und bis
dahin wäre das der Weg diese immensen
übergewinne abzugreifen und dann den
Menschen die es brauchen Unterstützung
zukommen zu lassen die Dinge seriös
durchzurechnen vor großzügigen
Ankündigungen dies forderte unterdessen
er wobei seinen anfangs mahnender
Tonfall am Ende beinahe trapatonisches
ausmaßnahmen immer werden irgendwelche
tollen Programme aufgelegt die sind Temp
begrenzt und zum Schluss landen die
Kosten bei uns ist machen wir nicht mehr
das ist einfach Ende Gelände ich mache
das einfach nicht mehr und ich werde im
Zukunft meine Zustimmung im Bundesrat
dafür nicht mehr geben immer dasselbe
Strickmuster man wird mit Investitionen
gelockt die sind nicht durchfinanziert
und das hängt uns zum Schluss in den
Haushalten damit muss endgültig Schluss
sein eine Ermahnung die seiner eigenen
Partei gilt und vor allem wohl der SPD
mit ihren nun aufgestellten Forderungen
Lars Klingbeil ist der SPD-Chef
schönen guten Abend Koalitionskrach in
der mega-krise ist das den Leuten zu
vermitteln
das ist kein Krach wir haben eine
Auseinandersetzung in der Sache ich bin
Robert Habeck sehr dankbar dass er jetzt
bei der gasumlage auch gesagt hat da
wird nachgebessert das ist auch richtig
das für das tun es ist den Menschen
nicht zu vermitteln dass Unternehmen die
Milliarden Gewinne machen jetzt noch
Milliarden Steuergelder oben drauf
bekommen also da muss nachgebessert
werden und insgesamt ist es so dass die
Regierung gerade mit Hochdruck am
dritten Entlastungspaket arbeitet und
ich bin mir sicher das wird sehr bald
kommen sehr bald sagen sie wie schwer
all das für sie ist in der Koalition das
merken wir auch daran dass dieser
Zeitplan doch immer noch relativ unklar
ist die Grünen wollen sehr sehr schnell
die FDP so wirkt das hat deutlich mehr
Zeit wann wird denn dieses nächste
Entlastungspaket konkret greifen können
es ist eine Frage jetzt von Tagen bis
das Entlastungspaket dann in der
Regierung in der Koalition auf den Weg
gebracht wurde verabschiedet wurde die
Gespräche laufen ich finde richtig dass
sie jetzt im Hintergrund laufen alle
sagen ja auch in diesen Tagen was sie
für wichtig halten es muss ein großes
Paket sein es muss zielgerichtet sein
und es muss den Menschen vor allem
signalisieren wie bringen sie jetzt
vernünftig durch die nächsten Monate die
eine große Herausforderung sind wir
haben das bei zwei entlastungspaketen
schon getan und das dritte kommt jetzt
dazu ein großes Entlastungspaket haben
sie gerade eben gesagt der FDP-Chef
Christian Lindner sagt Zitat kleinere
Entlastungen könne es womöglich noch
dieses Jahr geben größere aber erst 2023
das werden wir jetzt im Detail
besprechen ein paar Dinge liegen hier
auf dem Tisch die massive Ausweitung
beim Wohngeld das Bürgergeld auch die
Frage der steuerlichen Entlastung ich
glaube allerdings wir müssen ein Fehler
aus dem letzten
Entlastungspaket korrigieren wir haben
da die Rentnerinnen und Rentner
vergessen die sind auch hart betroffen
von den Energiepreisen die gerade nach
oben gehen wir müssen etwas für die
Studentinnen und Studenten tun und dich
sag ihnen noch ganz klar im Mittelpunkt
stehen diejenigen die hart arbeiten die
jeden Tag zur Arbeit gehen die 1500 2000
Euro Monat haben für die brauchen wir
jetzt auch substanzielle Entlastung das
alles muss jetzt zusammengebracht werden
und es muss schnell gehen es muss jetzt
zusammengebracht werden und es muss
schnell gehen die Zeit drängt in der Tat
auch wegen der Haushaltsberatungen im
Bundestag Herr kling weil das der
Tankrabatt am Mittwoch auslaufen würde
das war ja klar dass das 9 Euro Ticket
zum Beispiel am Mittwoch ebenfalls
ausläuft das war auch klar warum gibt es
denn zwei Tage davor noch immer keine
Klarheit ob und was genau danach kommt
wir haben ja beim 9 Euro Ticket ganz
klare Signale jetzt auch der
Verkehrsminister sagt er will jetzt eine
Weiterführung suchen die
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion die sich ja jetzt
gestern auch deutlich positioniert hat
sagt das auch noch die Grünen sagen dass
da so insofern bin ich sehr optimistisch
die Länder sagen zum Beispiel dass sie
mit der Finanzierung die sie da geplant
haben nicht einverstanden sind insofern
gibt es da doch noch wahnsinnig viel
Diskussionsbedarf offensichtlich und
keine klare Regel auf die die Leute sich
jetzt in dieser schwierigen Lage auch
verlassen könnten und mit der sie planen
könnten
es ist eine Krise die nicht geplant war
eine Krise in der wir gerade im Laufen
entscheiden müssen aber was wir
hinbekommen haben sind zwei große
entlastungspakete ich sage Ihnen wir
sind alle gewählt auch das 9 euro-ticket
in der Art und Weise vorzuführen das
muss jetzt aber mit den Ländern geklärt
werden aber das Signal das weitere
Entlastung kommen darauf können sich die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger verlassen gut Sie
haben es gerade schon vorhin kurz
angesprochen er klingt mal die gasumlage
da sollen wir jetzt also alle gemeinsam
alle Gaskunden wichtige Gasversorger
retten und merken gleichzeitig dass wir
auch die unterstützen die selbstkräftig
Geld machen wie naiv ist es denn in der
Politik darauf zu hoffen dass
Geschäftsleute wenn der Staat ihnen die
Möglichkeit dazu gibt nicht auch mal zu
Geschäfte machen werden
die Begründung für diese gasumlage die
mir gesagt wurde war es geht darum
Insolvenzen abzuwenden was nicht geht
ist das Gewinne maximiert werden was
nicht geht ist das Steuergelder noch auf
Milliardengewinne obendrauf gepackt
werden Robert Habeck hat jetzt gesagt er
lässt prüfen wie man diese Unternehmen
nicht unterstützt das muss entweder
politisch entschieden werden oder es
wird in der Verordnung entschieden am
Ende hat der Bundestag auch das
Schlusswort und ich sage ganz klar es
kann nicht sein dass diese Unternehmen
die Milliardengewinne machen dass die
noch Steuergeld oben drauf bekommen das
gibt auch eine Schieflage in der
Bevölkerung ich habe heute Abend eine
große Veranstaltung im Wahlkreis gehabt
die Menschen merken dass da gibt es
Widerspruch und deswegen darf das nicht
sein und das muss verhindert werden
jetzt reden sie allerdings so als sei es
noch gar nicht als Verordnung
beschlossen worden es ist ja bereits in
der Diskussion seit Wochen diese ganze
Geschichte und es trinkt sich so ein
bisschen der Eindruck auf dass hier
schneller es geht desto mehr Fehler
passieren in der Bundesregierung ich
sage nur erst der Tankrabatt und dann
die Hoffnung dass die Mineralölkonzerne
Ihnen eingeben mögen die
corona-test-zentren das war die letzte
Regierung ohne Kontrolle in der Hoffnung
dass wäre dann jeder auch sauber
hinterher abrechnen ist nicht passiert
wie wir heute wissen ist nicht absehbar
dass solche hoschusch-geschichten bei
denen es aber um Milliarden von Euros
geht dann am Ende auch ausgenutzt werden
es passieren in der tatfehler und ich
sehe das jetzt meine Aufgabe auch als
Parteivorsitzender Fehler die ich
wahrnehme deutlich anzusprechen
Korrekturen einzufordern aber ich sage
Ihnen auch ich habe hohen Respekt vor
einer Regierung die von Tag 1 sofort mit
großen Krisen belastet war die große
Krisen die nicht absehbaren als diese
Regierung zusammengekommen ist die mit
diesen Krisen zu handeln hat da gibt es
vieles für das gibt es kein Drehbuch da
können Fehler in der Tat passieren
wichtig ist für mich dass wir die Kraft
haben das auszusprechen und dass wir
dann die Kraft haben die Fehler schnell
zu korrigieren das tut Robert Habeck
jetzt das ist richtig und in meinen
Augen muss Politik in Krisenzeiten
genauso auch funktionieren eigentlich
dürften keine Fehler gemacht werden wenn
sie gemacht werden dann müssen sie
schnell korrigiert werden sagt der
SPD-Chef Lars Klingbeil vielen Dank
sehr gerne
und das Interview mit dem SPD-Chef haben
wir vor einer Stunde aufgezeichnet der
SPD Kanzler hat heute noch ganz andere
Herausforderungen auf dem Terminplan die
Sicherheitslage in Europa die älteste
Universität Mitteleuropas in Prag ist
für Olaf Scholz der Ort an dem er klar
machen will woher steht
zusammenfassend kann man das so sagen
der Bundeskanzler setzt auf eine
deutlich erweiterte EU mit deutlich
erweiterten Möglichkeiten auch etwa bei
der Verteidigung florian neuhahn hat die
Details dazu
als Olaf Scholz die alte Aula der Uni in
Prag betritt bemerkt ihn zunächst kaum
jemand der Applaus der dann einsetzt ist
er Verhalten ganz so wie wohl die
Stimmung gegenüber dem großen Nachbarn
Deutschland hat Scholz Regierung
entschieden genug reagiert auf Russlands
Krieg gegen die Ukraine
ich wünsche mir Deutschland als starken
Verbündeten nicht nur in der EU sondern
auch für die Ukraine das Deutschland als
ökonomisches Kraftzentrum der EU da mehr
tut
ich glaube nicht dass Deutschland genug
getan hat es hatte eine echte Chance als
großes Land mit seinen vielen
Fähigkeiten aber die Abhängigkeit vom
Gas in Russland hat es wohl gerade am
Anfang
gebremstance
hat sich diese historische Kulisse
ausgesucht für eine Grundsatzrede zur
Zukunft Europas jetzt will er die
Antworten liefern auf die Europa lange
gewartet hat und er will alles auf
einmal eine EU die schneller souveräner
militärisch mächtiger wird und die
zugleich wächst
ja die Ukraine die Republik Moldau
perspektivisch auch Georgien und
natürlich die sechs Staaten des
westlichen Balkans gehören zu uns zum
freien demokratischen Teil Europas ihr
EU-Beitritt liegt in unserem Interesse
doch ist diese EU überhaupt fit für eine
Erweiterung diese EU war der zuletzt
Victor Orban aus Ungarn beinahe das
letzte Sanktionspaket zu Fall gebracht
hätte Scholz hat seine Zweifel und er
bringt einen Dauerbrenner ins Spiel
Mehrheitsentscheidungen in der
gemeinsamen Außenpolitik
ein Festhalten am Prinzip der
Einstimmigkeit funktioniert nur solange
der Handlungsdruck gering ist
spätestens angesichts der Zeitenwende
aber ist das nicht mehr der Fall die
Zeitenwende es ist Scholz Überschrift
seit dem russischen Einmarsch in der
Ukraine und er will sie jetzt auf Europa
übertragen zum Beispiel mit einem
Luftabwehrsystem das Europa sich doch
gemeinsam zulegen könnte man Scholz
ein gemeinsam aufgebautes
Luftverteidigungssystem in Europa wäre
nicht nur kostengünstiger und
effizienter als wenn jeder von uns seine
eigene teure und hochkomplexe
Luftverteidigung aufbaut es wäre ein
Sicherheitsgewinn für ganz Europa es
klingt nach einem großen Projekt nur
nicht in den Ohren von Experten
vor zehn Jahren wäre das eine gute Idee
gewesen da hätte deutsche tatsächlich
nicht nur politisch sondern auch
militärisch Führung übernehmen können
denn damals gab es noch nicht
ausreichend Systeme und es war großer
Bedarf nach irgendjemand der die Führung
übernimmt mittlerweile hat fast ganz
Europa neue Systeme gekauft und
Deutschland hängt eigentlich hinterher
nach knapp einer Stunde hat Scholz sein
Publikum etwas müde geredet mit
dutzenden großen wie kleinen Vorschlägen
was davon Realität wird der Applaus
zeigt manche Skepsis ist wohl geblieben
und dazu kommt was sich der
Bundeskanzler wünscht ist ja die eine
Sache wie realistisch es ist das ist so
dann tatsächlich am Ende umgesetzt wird
die andere bringen wir also unseren
eu-korrespondenten mit dazu Florian
neuhan guten Abend Florian vielleicht
beginnen wir mal mit der Erweiterung die
der Bundeskanzler heute noch mal mit
Nachdruck gefordert hat da gibt es ja
manche Staaten die schon seit vielen
vielen Jahren in der Warteschleife
hängen werden wir denn eine deutlich
größere EU sehen in absehbarer Zeit
das klang ja heute bei Olaf Scholz ein
wenig so dass diese Erweiterung quasi
vor der Tür steht es wäre eine
Erweiterung um neuen Staaten die Olaf
Scholz heute nannte eine Erweiterung des
Gesicht der EU massiv verändern würde
das Kraftzentrum Richtung Osten
verschieben würde und die
Ungleichgewichte zwischen den einzelnen
Staaten massiv erhöhen werde aber
natürlich steht das wichtigste steht das
mitnichten gleich vor der Tür im
Gegenteil es liegt einerseits eben an
den Staaten den Beitrittskandidaten dass
sie erstmal noch viele Reformen umsetzen
müssen den Rechtsbestand der EU umsetzen
müssen und das wird noch viele Jahre
dauern da soll es das sagte Scholz an
anderer Stelle auch keine Rabatte geben
und andererseits gibt es auf den Seiten
der alten EU der jetzigen Mitglieder
große Vorbehalte dann müsste Scholz nur
gucken etwa in die Niederlande zu Mark
rütte oder nach Frankreich zu deinem
wichtigsten Verbündeten Emanuel macron
beide haben immer wieder gesagt dass sie
große Vorbehalte haben also bis wir eine
solche mega Erweiterung sehen da dürfte
hier in Prag noch viel Wasser die Moldau
hinunter fließen und allerspätestens bei
so einer Erweiterung also wirklich
allerspätestens bräuchten wir dann ja
auch eine deutlich beweglichere EU da
gibt es ja diesen Zwang zur
Einstimmigkeit der enorm lärmt auch
schon in der Vergangenheit immer wieder
auch da will Bundeskanzler Scholz ran
mit welchen Aussichten
auch nicht sonderlich großen das ist ein
Dauerbrenner der europäischen
Reformdebatte an der sich seit Jahren
versucht wird seit die EU sich an einer
gemeinsamen Außenpolitik versucht aber
auch diesmal sind die Erfolgsaussichten
nicht sonderlich groß das hat Olaf
Scholz hier in Prag bereits erleben
dürfen am Nachmittag bei einer
Pressekonferenz mit einem tschechischen
Gastgeber mit Peter Fiala dem
tschechischen premier der nämlich gesagt
hatte dass seine Regierung dass eher
skeptisch sieht und dann schaut man
weiter eben nach Ungarn zum Beispiel wo
Viktor Orban ja keinesfalls sich dieses
Machtmittel dieses Vetorecht aus der
Hand reißen lassen wird die EU müsste
sich einstimmig dazu durchringen sich
von dieser Einstimmigkeit zu
verabschieden das erscheint mir wenig
realistisch im Gegenteil diese Idee
einer Mehrheitsentscheidung ist wohl
eher so etwas wie eine ja ich würde
sagen Vater Morgana der europäischen
Reformdebatte die immer mal wieder
aufscheint und auch durchaus verlockend
erscheint die sich aber bei näherem
Hinsehen dann als nicht wirklich real
erweist
Florian vielen Dank für diese Analyse
live aus Prag heute Abend und die
Übersicht über weitere wichtige
Nachrichten an diesem Tag jetzt von dir
Hanna
tonnenweise tote Fische mussten ja seit
Anfang August aus der oder gefischt
werden nun soll eine deutsch-polnische
Expertengruppe bis Ende September die
Ursache dafür klären das ist das
Ergebnis eines Treffens von
Bundesumweltministerin Lemke und ihrer
polnischen Amtskollegin Moskva keine
Einigkeit gab es dagegen bei der Frage
des oderausbaus während Lemke sich für
einen Stopp aussprach damit sich das
Ökosystem des Flusses wieder erholen
kann will Polen den Ausbau weiter
vorantreiben
am Morgen ist ein weiteres
Steinkohlekraftwerk aus der sogenannten
Reserve geholt worden das vom
Energiekonzern uniper betriebene
Kraftwerk Heiden in Petershagen ist
wieder am Netz es ist eines der
leistungsstärksten Kraftwerke in
Deutschland und der mit Kohle
produzierte Strom soll helfen Erdgas
einzusparen
peace bezeichnete den Schritt als bitter
aber unumgänglich
52 Millionen verkaufte Tickets und mehr
Menschen in Bussen und Bahnen der
Verband Deutscher Verkehrsunternehmen
wertet das 9 euro-ticket als Erfolg laut
einer repräsentativen Umfrage des
Verbands haben zehn Prozent der Fahrten
mit dem Ticket eine Autofahrt ersetzt
gemeinsam mit den verkehrsministerinnen
und Ministern der Länder fordern die
Unternehmen eine Nachfolgelösung sowie
mehr Geld vom Bund für den Ausbau des
Nahverkehrs
seit Monaten steckt der Irak in einer
tiefen politischen Krise nun haben
Anhänger des schiitenführers als Sabre
den Regierungspalast in Bagdad gestürmt
kurz zuvor hat er der Geistliche seinen
Rückzug aus der Politik angekündigt bei
den Zusammenstößen sollen mindestens
zehn Menschen getötet und zahlreiche
weitere verletzt worden sein auch fast
ein Jahr nach der Parlamentswahl hat der
Irak keine Regierung und die Bevölkerung
leidet unter einer massiven
Wirtschaftskrise
nach den schweren Überschwemmungen in
Pakistan ist erste internationale Hilfe
eingetroffen mehrere Flugzeuge mit
Hilfsgütern hätten die betroffenen
Gebiete erreicht erklärte
Premierminister Sharif durch die
ungewöhnlich starken Monsunregen sind
seit Juni mehr als 1.000 Menschen
gestorben die Sturzfluten rissen ganze
Dörfer mit sich mehr als 33 Millionen
Menschen sind laut Behörden von den
Überschwemmungen betroffen
was ist wirklich los hier am größten
Atomkraftwerk Europas in saporicia
Ukraine wie hoch ist die Gefahr dass zum
Grauen des Krieges dort auch noch das
Grauen eines nuklearen Störfalls kommt
klar ist noch nie in der Geschichte der
zivilen Atomkraft hat es Kämpfe Beschuss
Raketen direkt an einem Reaktor gegeben
immer wieder scheint ja sogar die Anlage
selbst zum Ziel zu werden die halbe Welt
erhofft sich mehr Informationen erhofft
sich Überprüfung und Kontrolle von einer
heiklen Mission zu der Experten der
Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde samt
ihrem Chef jetzt unterwegs sind Arndt
Ginzel und Joachim Barz haben mit
Mitarbeitern der Atomanlage gesprochen
Sergej Schwert gehörte zum
Sicherheitsdienst des Atomkraftwerks
saporicia und verteidigte es als am
dritten märz die russischen Panzer kamen
bilder einer Überwachungskamera
mit Panzern haben sie uns zurückgedrängt
wir gaben auf es hat er ja keinen Sinn
mehr zwei Kugeln haben meinen Kopf
gestreift
seine Waffe eine Kalaschnikow versteckte
er in seiner Wohnung bis ihn jemand
verriet russische Soldaten traten seine
Wohnungstür ein und begannen zu schießen
das ist das Ergebnis fünf Kugeln haben
mich erwischt fußarm Schenkel Wange
wurden getroffen eine Kugel wurde aus
meinem Bauch rausgeholt
seit das Atomkraftwerk saporicia
russisch besetzt ist herrscht dort ein
Klima der Angst und des Terrors sagen
zeugen
wir treffen einen Ingenieur der bis Ende
Juli im Atomkraftwerk arbeitete und dann
Flo er will nicht erkannt werden
die Russen haben in Kellern Gefängnisse
eingerichtet und foltern dort
Mitarbeiter die gegen die Besatzung
protestieren ihnen wird in die Beine
oder in die Hände geschossen wir
vermissen 10 bis 20 Kollegen wo sind sie
die russischen Besatzer hätten schwere
Waffen neben den Reaktoren postiert und
würden auf ukrainische Gebiete schießen
jede Nacht feuern sie auf die anderen
Seite es wird aber nicht
zurückgeschossen weil jeder versteht
dass das ein Atomkraftwerk ist
die Kämpfe rund um das Atomkraftwerk
halten an heute Nacht wurde Ernährung da
getroffen die Stadt der Ingenieure in
unmittelbarer Nähe des Kernkraftwerks
um die Sicherheitslage vor Ort zu
inspizieren will in wenigen Tagen ein
Expertenteam der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde anreisen
Generaldirektor Raphael Mariano grossi
veröffentlicht heute dieses Foto der
Delegation sie komme viel zu spät meint
eine Mitarbeiterin die im Atomkraftwerk
arbeitet und die wir heute erreichen
auch sie will nicht erkannt werden
die Atomenergiebehörde hat nichts
gemacht um eine nukleare Katastrophe zu
verhindern die hier jederzeit passieren
kann wegen dieser Untätigkeit hat die
Belegschaft kein Vertrauen zu dieser
Organisation die Delegation meint die
Mitarbeiterin wird von den Russen
belogen werden
die russischen Soldaten werden den AKW
Mitarbeitern niemals erlauben zu
erzählen was wirklich passiert sie
werden nicht zeigen dürfen von wo aus
geschossen wird dabei haben es alle
gesehen auch heute Nacht wieder vom AKW
Gelände aus auf das andere Ufer
die Lage am russisch besetzten
Atomkraftwerks operissia wird immer
bedrohlicher
im Laufe dieser Woche wird das
internationale Expertenteam dann dort
erwartet es wird höchste Zeit
nochmal Hanna jetzt nicht nur das Gas
ist ein Problem auch die aktuellen
Strompreise werden immer zu einem
größeren Problem ja alles wird teurer
mit spürbaren Folgen obwohl die Löhne im
vergangenen Quartal gestiegen sind
können sich Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer in Deutschland immer
weniger leisten durch die hohe Inflation
sind die Reallöhne erneut gesunken und
zwar laut dem Statistischen Bundesamt um
4,4 Prozent schon im ersten Quartal gab
es ein Minus von 1,8 Prozent und im
Herbst könnte sich die Situation durch
eine steigende Inflation weiter
verschärfen die Reallöhne sinken also
was dagegen massiv steigt sind die
Strompreise und das liegt auch am teuren
Gas Valerie Haller in Frankfurt wie ist
da genau der Zusammenhang ja der Preis
und der Strombörse ist immer gekoppelt
an den teuersten Stromproduzenten das
sind aufgrund der hohen Nachfrage
momentan die Gaskraftwerke warum damit
sollen nämlich günstige Anbieter
gefördert werden denn wer günstig Strom
produziert der profitiert von den hohen
Preisen am meisten weil er den Strom bei
vergleichsweise niedrigen
Herstellungskosten teuer verkaufen kann
und in der Regel sind das eben die
Anbieter von Ökostrom deren Rohstoffe
Wind Sonne Wasser die kosten ja
praktisch nichts das System hat lange
gut funktioniert aber jetzt da Gas so
teuer geworden ist schnell die
Strompreise ebenfalls stark in die Höhe
und belasten den Stromkunden kleine
Entwarnung die Preise von der Strombörse
kommen erst zeitverzögert beim
Stromkunden an und dann auch nicht in
vollem Umfang nun wird an der EU über
eine Reform des Strommarktes diskutiert
wie könnte das aussehen da gibt es ganz
verschiedene Vorstellungen noch nichts
fixes eine ist die staatliche
Preisregulierung also ein
strompreisdeckel vor allem aber steht
die Idee im Raum eben genau diese
Koppelung an den Gaspreis aufzuheben was
stromexperten und Befürworter der
Energiewende aber ganz strikt ablehnen
anderem weil bei sinkenden Preisen
weniger anreizbestände Strom zu sparen
die Bundesregierung dürfte sich aber
darauf konzentrieren den Verbraucher
zielgerichte zu entlasten vielen Dank
Valerie nach Frankfurt
vor der Küste von Schweden werden
Familien mit Kindern und ältere
Passagiere mit Hilfe von Helikoptern von
einer in Brand geratenen Autofähre
evakuiert die Situation sei jedoch unter
Kontrolle meldet die schwedische
Schifffahrtsbehörde nach einem Brand an
Bord sei der Strom ausgefallen die faire
treibe nun bei starkem Wind langsam auf
die Insel Gotland zu
der Countdown lief bereits doch dann
musste die NASA den für heute geplanten
Start der neuen Mars Mondmission Artemis
1 kurzfristig absagen der Grund ein
triebwerkproblem der nächste Start
Versuch kann frühestens am Freitag
stattfinden der unbemannte Testflug ist
ein wichtiger Schritt für die NASA um ab
2025 auch wieder Menschen auf den Mond
zu schicken
und jetzt zum Tennis in New York haben
heute die US Open begonnen allerdings
mit einer Niederlage der deutschen
Tennisspielerin Tatjana Maria die
Wimbledon halbfinalistin ist in der
ersten Runde gegen die Weltranglisten
dritte Maria saccari aus Griechenland
ausgeschieden die 35-Jährige aus Bad
Saulgau unterlag sakhari in drei Sätzen
mit vier zu sechs sechs zu drei und null
zu sechs
und das war unsere Welt an diesem
letzten Montag im August danke dass Sie
mit dabei waren und noch der Hinweis auf
unser heute journal Update gegen 0:10
Uhr mit Gundula gauser von uns sagen
hier im Team an sie einen angenehmen
[Musik]
guten Abend auch wenn der August noch
nicht völlig vorbei ist die
niederschlagsbilanz ist eher
niederschmetternd besonders im Westen
und im Nordwesten da fielen zum Teil nur
0 bis 15 Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter in
anderen Regionen wie zum Beispiel am
Alpenrand fiel das Doppelte bis
Dreifache dessen was man im ganzen Monat
erwarten könnte und jetzt in den letzten
paar Tagen kommt kaum noch Regen dazu
sie sehen aber wie die Luft hier von
Frankreich hier schwüler wird da
entwickeln sich dann im Süden doch
einige Schauer und Gewitter auch wenn
die Tiefs viel Abstand von uns halten
heute Nacht gibt es etwas Regen an der
Ostsee sonst ist es zum Teil auch klar
es bindet sich hier und da mal etwas
Nebel die Temperaturen sinken meist auf
13 bis 8 Grad an der Ostsee an der
Nordsee und dem Rhein-Main-Gebiet bleibt
es 15 Grad milder die Höchsttemperaturen
morgen liegen im Norden und Nordosten
meist so bei 19 bis 22 Grad sonst werden
23 bis 30 Grad erreicht und nach dem
etwas Nebel oder Dunst am Morgen ist das
morgen erstmal ein freundlicher Tag es
gibt noch letzte Regenschauer im
Nordosten aber von Südwesten wird die
Luft schon wieder schwüger und es
entwickeln sich die ersten Gewitter und
die ziehen dann in der Nacht zum
Mittwoch und Mittwoch über Tag weiter
über Baden-Württemberg und erreichen
dann auch Bayern in Norddeutschland
bleibt es dagegen sehr sonnig der
Donnerstag wird ruhig der Freitag bringt
Gewitter im Südwesten guten Abend